So, I was a C- student in school.
I went to one of the best schools in Washington, DC.
And I think that out of 100 students, I was the 100th student.
I was, at best, a C- student.
But I had a couple of teachers.
One I'll remember forever is, his name is Harvey Lesure, my tenth grade American History teacher.
Even though I was the worst student in the class, Harvey Lesure saw something.
He made me feel, I don't know how he did it, like some great magician...
...he made me feel like I had something to say.
So when I feel like the issue is too complex,...
...too hard to grasp, impossible fixing our schools,...
...I go to the place that I did when I first started making this movie:...
...that we're never gonna have great schools without great teachers.
So if you're looking for a way to get involved,...
...if you're looking for a way to give every kid in America a great education,...
...it starts with great teachers.
Become a teacher.
Help a teacher.
Be part of appreciating the role teachers have in our society.
That is the answer.
We're never going to have great schools without great teachers.